hello everyone and welcome to the final
leg of the grand prix Vita Grand Prix
being played in Jerusalem it's Wesley
soul versus you and ye it's the second
round all of the games from round one
ended in a draw
it's a it's very interesting game I'm
sure you're gonna enjoy it but before we
check out the game we do have a few
interesting photos so here's a nice
photo of Wesley versus you young ye and
you can see only a few moves have been
played on the board
Wesley without any refreshments but you
can get with with a nice cup of
something and already half of the
chocolate is missing now that's that's
pretty weird if you ask me because only
a few moves have been played
so either young he really likes
chocolate or he you know ate half of it
in the previous round and brought the
other half to round two so the you know
it something to be discussed I'm sure
and also here's a very nice photo of
Boris Gelfand just opening up a nice
bottle of water so not I don't know if
you will play any interesting games so
just in case he doesn't we will show a
few photos of him so there we have it
all the photos of courtesy of Nicky Riga
so I do hope you enjoyed that as well
and also if you're interested in
supporting Nicky's work she published a
calendar and there you have it 2020
calendar where there are 12 very nice
photos featured throughout throughout
her career as a photographer she picked
them herself
so if you want to check that out I will
also include links to that in the
description below here are the context
but for those of you who are you know
lazy or something I will just put some
links in the comment section where you
will be able to contact her that being
said let's check out the game and now
Wesley with the white pieces opens with
E for ya we have 'if I've sorry about
that
Knight to f3 and Knight to f6 young he
goes for the petrol of Defense with d4
challenging the central right away
Knight captures on e4 and now Bishop to
d3 is the main main idea here it's the
most popular move played today but we
have D captures an e5 by Wesley and okay
we have d5 now asking do you wanna cap
from Poisson and if white captures black
has no problems here he just took
continuous development castles and all
the pieces are
nicely developed if anything black is
even up in you know better in
development so after d5 we have Knight
bTW - now we've captured some d2 bishop
characters and now Bishop to e7 young he
prepares the castle with Bishop to d3
and the now c5 now c3 making room for
the bishop and c2 also preventing d4 we
have Knight to c6 and we have castles by
Wesley Bishop to g4 now pinning the
knight and rook to e1 you have to be
careful h3 would be a big big blunder
here because you allow Knight captures
an e5 where the bishop on d3 is just
hanging so yeah you do grab the piece
but then black recaptures and black is
up a pawn in a much better position so
after rook to e1 you add another
defender to the e5 pawn and now Queen to
d7 and now h3 now you can play it
because knife captors and e5 is not a
possibility
Bishop to h5 and now Bishop to f4
following the game Greek versus Caruana
from the 2018 candidates tournament we
have Queen to e6 and now comes Bishop to
e2 now Grisha played a three against
Caruana and Caruana won that game in the
candidates tournament and for those of
you who are who maybe don't know this
now as of yesterday
Alexander Grisha is officially in the
candidates tournament 2020 so just in
case you didn't know that now you do so
there is only one more spot left to
qualify through the Grand Prix and we'll
see who will be able to do it we'll MVL
finally get his spot in the candidates
tournament but here we have Bishop to e2
and it is a new move so as we move 13 we
have a completely new game we have
castles by young G and now Queen to d2
now the Queen can be developed since you
no longer have to keep an eye on the
night with the Queen
we have worshipped the g6 and now rook 8
and d1 just getting the rook into the
game Bishop to c4 an excellent Square
for the bishop however it allows Knight
to g5 which wins the bishop pair so here
black will part either with this Bishop
sends the Queen and the Bishop are under
attack or you have to give up the dark
square Bishop so you young G decides to
give up the darks
we have Bishop characters and g5 and h6
pushing the bishop back making room for
the bishop on h7 if needed Bishop back
the e3 and now d4 we have seek after
sandy four and now rook F to d8
preparing to recapture here since the
queen is on D - you cannot capture any
more any more pawns with Queen to c3 and
now you could grab it right away and
then play Queen to g6 but you and egos
Queen to g6 first now he threatens mate
so there's always time to recapture on
d4 we have g3 preventing mate and the
now see captures on d4 with bishop
characters on d4 and the Queen to ecigs
now going after the h3 pawn we have King
to h2 defending at internal rook a to c8
just getting that final rook into the
game already threatening some very nice
discoveries as the rope again occupies
the same file as the Queen Queen back
the e3 unpinning and also attacking the
bishop while also attacking the a7 pawn
with Bishop to f5 going after the h3
pawn and here white has to decide g4 is
definitely a possibility if g4 we go
into rooked a bishop to c2 attacking the
rook and after rook to d2 not just
Knight captures on d4 now also the rope
guards the bishop here rook captures on
d4 and now Queen captures an a - so wife
will give up some point here a point
here but it's not a problem because
White will get an excellent attack after
Bishop c4 now you put pressure on the f7
pawn Queen captures and now rook
captures on d8 rook captures and Queen
to f4 and with this f7 pawn being
pressured yes you can go - up to g6 but
then e 6 is also coming and you are
somewhat opening up for the blacks Kings
defenses but instead of this g4 move
Wesley finds an even nicer one it's
Bishop to c3 now saying okay you can
capture on h3 but if you capture on h3
now I have Queen to f4 prepared now I am
threatening to trap your Bishop just
with g4 but also Bishop to c4 is coming
so it's gonna be very hard for black to
wiggle out of this one for example if
rook captures you just play Bishop
captures and after the bishop moves back
you don't want to allow it to stay there
to be trapped now
you play g4 and after the bishop moves
now you go Bishop to b3 and it's a very
tough position for black to play black
queen has to move now you can play even
east six and white is breaking through
so that's what Wesley had in mind when
he played Bishop to see three young he
is not interested in h3 first he plays
rook capture sandy one we have rook
after sandy one and now Queen captures
on a two grabbing a pawn we have g4 by
Wesley versa back the e6 not allowing
the the light-square bishop to occupy
this diagonal so Queen to e4 now with
ideas of maybe you can remain over the
bishop here to threaten the King side
this way it's not going to be possible
to defend with g6 and then just h4 you
can just easily bust open the position
so here black decided to go for Knight
to e7 he gave up the b7 pawn at a try
and consolidate this way Wesley captured
them b7 and now Knight to d5 hoping to
trade bishop for tonight but Wesley
guards the bishop repair we have
Bishop them at d4 and the now comes a
five pushing the pawn we have blush of
the f3 now putting pressure on the on
the knight here preparing to bring the
bishop over to this diagonal we have
Queen to c4 and Danaus b3 pushing the
Queen back preventing a four we have
Queen to c2 now putting pressure on the
rook here even though the the rook is
protected for the moment but here Wesley
has a really excellent move so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
this excellent move I just mentioned
well I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such an
excellent move and for the Dukes we just
want to enjoy the show
it's Bishop captures and d5 yes you
leave the rook undefended and the
problem is if you go Queen captures on
d1 then you have Bishop captures on e6
you remove the defender of the rook so
black doesn't have time to capture
either of the bishops you're gonna have
to move the route back because even this
is a threat this is a threat because f7
is also hanging so rook the f8 and now
you're gonna go Bishop to c5 and now you
basically trade down into this Queen and
pawn endgame Bishop captures Queen cap
captors and now kingi to improving the
safety of the kingside pawns and you you
go into the simian where a white is up
upon and it's gonna be hard for blacks
to defense so this was Wesley's idea if
black goes for the rook
so of course you young ego went after
the bishop with Bishop character son b5
first Queen captures and only now Queen
captures on d1 so here
Wesley's down the exchange but he has
east six and that's the problem of
course you cannot capture because after
Queen captures a width check King h7 you
don't capture the roof right away first
you deliver check force the King back
and then you capture the rook with check
or just g6 and Queen to f7 is made sense
the bishop slices through the dark
square diagonal so after each six we
have Queen to c2 and now comes just he
captures on f7 with check the black
Queen needs access to g6 and here with
King to f8 it's still possible to play
if King to f8 then you get Queen d6
check King captures on f7 now Queen d7
check the black Queen guards the rook so
that's good for black King back to f8
and now Queen captures and g7 check King
g8 and Queen captures on h6 so here ok
black will probably capture on b3 and
you get this position where white is up
to pawns but black is up the exchange
and has a past
a pawn however with the black King being
so you know there bare naked and the
open board it's it's only white who can
win this game it's it's impossible for
black to do anything here especially
with the dark square Bishop guarding the
f2 pawn black will never create any sort
of an attack against the black King
against the white king so but it was
still possible to hope for something
there however young he went King to h7
and now it's just completely lost I feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the winning move for white awhile I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations and punishing such such
a huge blunder like King to h7 and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
Queen to d6 is possible but Queen to e5
is just much faster it threatens mate
and there's only one way to prevent mate
which doesn't really
helped black its Queen to g6 which is
what young he played and here Wesley
just played Queen to e7 and it was in
this position that young year resigned
the game and since since this is game
two he is also eliminated from the
Jerusalem Grand Prix 2019 since the
first game in the draw end game two went
to Wesley there is just no move you can
play to prevent f8 Queen
so f8 Queen is coming you're gonna have
to give up the rook and then it's just
unplayable for black so whatever you do
here f8 Queen wins the game there there
is no way to block it you cannot go
something there is no move that even
prolongs the game here so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Matteo Bruno Michael Rosen
Johnny Adams dhanunjay Bharadwaj and
Carlos Carranza for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the fede
grand prix to see who alongside
alexander Grisha will qualify for the
candidates tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world so do
check out the links to the to the nice
calendar in the description below and
also don't forget to be a part of the
subscribers video 2020 more explanation
on that in the description block if you
if you still don't know what at what
that is so thank you I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day